I'm sure you heard what happened in
Sweden earlier today why did it happen
well there are a lot of followers of
Muhammad who are in panic mode because
of what they call the Avalanche of
apostasy and they're lashing out to make
themselves feel like they're still
strong even as the apostasy rates
Skyrocket turning to violence is a
desperate and pathetic move that's only
going to accelerate the Avalanche but
there is a legitimate concern right now
for critics of Islam who might be
targeted and one of the highest profile
Targets in recent years has been hatun
Tash hatun is an ex-muslim from Turkey
lots of people are familiar with hatun
from her work at Speaker's Corner she
was the one who more than any other
single person was responsible for
obliterating the perfect preservation
lie she showed up to Speaker's Corner
with 26 different Arabic krans and this
caused a chain reaction that led to the
infamous holes in the narrative
interview she's also been physically
attacked repeatedly at Speaker's Corner
she's been arrested by British police
who tried to appease the mob by
arresting hatun instead of protecting
her she sued the police and forced them
to apologize she was also the target of
a foiled assassination plot a Jihadi is
serving at least 16 years for a plot to
take her out but whatever you've seen
about hatsun on YouTube or from the
media you don't know a thousandth of
what she does or what she's been through
here's what she normally does as Muslims
are heading to the mosque for their
prayers hatun will approach one of them
and start a conversation with him or her
and she'll continue talking to the
Muslim as they walk into the mosque in
the mosque she'll be directed to the
women's section she's not there to
disrupt anything but after the prayers
there's a time for discussion and she'll
start asking the women questions about
Islam the women will have absolutely no
clue how to answer so they'll go get
their husbands the husbands will have
absolutely no clue how to answer so
they'll go get their Imam or the local
shik then hatsun will completely expose
Islam right in front of everybody and
people walk out of there wondering what
just happened it's pretty amazing and
she doesn't just talk to Muslims she'll
walk right up to prostitutes on street
corners and share the gospel with
them if you've seen the videos of her
being attacked keep in mind that she's
been physically attacked way more than
that she just doesn't publicize it and
she doesn't seem to like it when we
mention it and now I'm going to mention
something else that people don't know I
didn't get permission to share this but
I'm doing it anyway because Christians
need to know it hatun is staying with
some people right now but there have
been a lot of times where she's been
homeless she can't rent a place to live
in the UK if she rents an apartment
police show up and warn everyone else in
the building that they're all in danger
because of her and then she gets kicked
out so what does she do does she back
down does she give up no she doesn't
complain she just keeps doing what she's
doing and she sleeps under a bridge she
sleeps in a
tent there's a part of me that thinks
hey there's something admirable and cool
about that but there's another part of
me that thinks hatun is a woman she's a
high priority Target for jihadis she's
one of the greatest Christian Warriors
in history she shouldn't be in a
situation where she has to stay under a
bridge because people are scared to be
around her
again she's fine now she's staying with
some people but it's not permanent and
she travels around as much as she's able
as you're hearing this I'm sure many of
you are thinking we'd love to help atun
she just doesn't ask that's the problem
hatun doesn't like asking for money she
doesn't like other people asking for
money for her years ago after she was
attacked J Smith put up a fundraiser to
hire security for her she told him to
take it down hatun could be starving I
don't think she'd ask for
money but if someone doesn't like taking
money there's a pretty easy solution all
you have to do is say look here's some
money to support your work and take care
of your needs if you don't accept this
we're going to send it to Ali
dawa and then what's she going to do
turn down the money and fund dawa so
we've got a patreon set up for haton
goes straight to her she doesn't go to
speaker Corner much anymore because she
can get way more done keeping a low
profile and just going around talking to
Muslims wherever she can find them let's
all chip in and make sure that anytime
she needs a place to stay hotel whatever
or needs to catch an Uber or needs a
plane ticket because she loves going
from town to town city to City going to
all the Muslim areas let's make sure her
costs are covered I think that's the
least we can do so the link to the
patreon is in the description box and if
you're watching this hatun no I'm not
taking down this video and if you ever
turn down anything we are giving you I
promise you we will give it to Ali dawa
[Music]